the kings and queens of catastrophe for
the left these days everything is a
disaster all of the alarms have sounded
it would be catastrophic I think that
would be a catastrophe
there's not almost no souls in
Washington who believe that there's this
other anything other than a completing
another catastrophe some people are
predicting the apocalypse the apocalypse
this week of course it was the corona
virus a corona virus is spreading and
the numbers just just stunning at this
point lives are at stake
could be truly catastrophic if it can
impact a fifth of the population it
would be a catastrophe yes yes but this
is what they always do a few months ago
it was a looming economic catastrophe I
think that's where this talk of the
Trump recession is really starting to
build up a lot of global leaders are
blaming Trump for the global recession
that we're seeing president Trump is
pushing us into a recession we're
feeling it in so many different ways and
it will be the Trump recession then like
this have a climate change number one
the biggest problem facing the world is
climate change because it can kill us
all climate change will affect
everything that we do in our nation the
world is going to end in 12 years if we
don't address climate change over the
Soleimani strike they said it was the
start of World War three we are suddenly
at an extremely perilous moment
following one reckless act by the
American president the chances for war
are more serious now than they have been
in the last 40 years here we are today
closer to war with Iran than we've ever
been when it's not a health economic
environmental security catastrophe it's
a catastrophe of democracy we're not
going to let him just you know torch
this democracy this is something to save
our country that must be stopped his
assault on the rule of law we have a
president who doesn't believe in the
rule of law he doesn't believe in
freedom of the press but it's all just
an illusion the recession they talked
about never came in fact the economy got
even stronger with the last jobs report
exceed
eating expectations earnings continuing
to grow and consumer confidence
remaining high on climate change our
emissions are actually going down not up
in fact last year America had the
biggest reduction of any country in the
world globally deaths and economic
losses from natural disasters are five
times lower than in 1980 not to mention
the fact that the earth is actually
becoming greener as we speak that
Armageddon they predicted after
President Trump took out one of the
world's most dangerous terrorists we're
still waiting the collapse of the rule
of law here at home tell that to
President Trump who's constantly being
thwarted and frustrated by the Congress
and courts on everything from executive
power to pardons to immigration policy I
think you'll find that checks and
balances are working pretty well too
well for some people's liking as for
Trump curtailing the freedom of the
press my god can anyone think of a
president who faced a more hostile media
than this one after their endless
predictions of imminent disaster on
every subject forgive us if we don't
take the Democrats and their allies on
ruling class state TV seriously with
their latest catastrophizing on
coronavirus of course it's serious and
we should take sensible precautions
while they were busy impeaching him
that's exactly what President Trump was
doing closing the border to high risk
risk visitors and getting going on a
vaccine the president announced more
travel restrictions yesterday and that's
great but he should go even further
before anyone screams that's racist and
extreme check out this column from the
New York Times epidemic expert Donald
McNeal he was literally the person that
Rachel Maddow put on her show this week
as her voice of reason
he backs tough travel restrictions
writing harsh measures horrify civil
libertarians but they often save lives
especially when they are imposed in the
early days three other practical steps
make sure Americans don't get charged
for coronavirus testing make sure people
get paid sick leave so there's no
economic incentive to come to work and
spread germs and just to stop the Trump
haters bleating about politicization
have a daily press briefing from a
medical expert speaking of which
listen to doctor foul Qi day chorus
don't muzzle doctor foul Qi first of all
he's not been muzzled as he himself said
but the big point is this yes let's
listen to dr. foul Qi and what did he
say yesterday the highest coronavirus
risk is for people with heart disease
chronic lung disease diabetes and
obesity every single one of those things
is preventable but instead of trying to
prevent them we actively encourage them
for example on heart disease and obesity
with totally corrupt members of Congress
in both parties totally corrupt state
legislators in both parties doing the
bidding of big food and big agriculture
by subsidizing food that kills us and
penalizing food that's good for us but
as usual the idiot media and the idiot
politicians chase superficial nonsense
instead of addressing the underlying
issue so let's get things in proportion
over 10 million Americans got the flu
over the past year how many have caught
this variant of flu in America so far
it's four but the facts and the science
don't matter to their kings and queens
of catastrophe they need catastrophe for
their twin obsessions growing the
government and hating Trump but suppose
a proposal now that is meager anemic in
terms of addressing is what the quiz
Ebola we did five billion now they're
trying to take the bowl among money and
spend
here so what he's doing is late too late
for words describe the administration's
response to the coronavirus towering and
dangerous incompetence towering and
dangerous in Thompson's he loves those
four words he actually said it five
times in 24 hours
meanwhile the media keep comparing
coronavirus to Ebola is there somebody
who is in charge of coronavirus response
for the whole US government the way that
President Obama puts somebody in charge
of the Ebola response the first month I
was White House of all response
coordinator I did no press interviews I
was in there every day 18 hours a day
congratulations Ron but for goodness
sake Leah bollock of Paris is a
ridiculous according to China's CDC the
coronavirus death rate in China is
naught point nine percent for healthy
adults the death rate for Ebola was
ninety percent a hundred times worse
while the Trump administration is taking
sensible steps based on science the 2020
Democrats are pushing stupid stunts
based on political prejudice and Dogma
Elizabeth Warren wants to take money
from border security because obviously
opening our borders is a brilliant way
to fight the disease spreading across
countries what we've seen this week is
the media and the politicians unhealthy
addiction to drama and hype listen to an
actual health official said
coronaviruses are responsible for the
common cold so it's something that all
of you may also be quite familiar with
the cause of the current outbreak that
originated in China is a little
of this family our experience today
though is that most people more than 85%
will have milder nose symptoms most
people will have mild or no symptoms in
the end the facts are always a letdown
for the kings and queens of catastrophe
coronavirus properly managed the
environment getting better the economy
getting stronger and as we saw just this
week with president Trump's triumphant
visit to India remember that America
more respected around the world